qué porcentaje es 100 de 80 este tipo de
problemas aunque son muy simples le
rompen la cabeza a mucha gente pues
piensan que saca el porcentaje de 80 o
el porcentaje de 100 multiplicó por cien
dividido entre 80 al final de cuentas no
está claro y lo que hay que hacer para
empezar es leer muy bien el problema
para entender qué es lo que nos están
pidiendo en este caso no están diciendo
que esté 100 es un porcentaje de 80 y
ese porcentaje es el que hay que
calcular es este qué porcentaje que nos
preguntan así es que si multiplicamos 80
por ese porcentaje que vamos a calcular
vamos a obtener 100 pongámoslo así
tenemos 80 que hay que multiplicar por
cierta cantidad por este porcentaje
llamémosle x voy a poner lo mejor con
otro color por x 80 por x de tal manera
que cuando multiplicamos 80 por ese
porcentaje vamos a obtener 100 al
resolver esta ecuación así como esta
vamos a obtener un valor de x y entonces
convertiremos ese valor de x en un
porcentaje así es que la pregunta la
hemos puesto como 100 es lo que
obtenemos al multiplicar 80 por qué
número y una vez que obtengamos ese
número convertirlo en porcentaje
básicamente está la ecuación y ahora la
vamos a resolver dividiendo entre 80
ambos lados dividimos entre 80 el lado
izquierdo y dividimos entre 80 el lado
derecho y nos queda del lado izquierdo
simplemente x y del lado derecho nos
queda 100 sobre 80 vamos a simplificar
esto ambos tienen como factor común el
máximo común divisor es 20 100 dividido
entre 25 y 80 dividido entre 20 es 4
hemos obtenido que x es igual a 5
cuartos pero x está expresado como una
fracción y nos están preguntando qué
porcentaje es 180 si nos hubieran
preguntado qué fracción es 180 entonces
afirmar que tienes 5 cuartos de 80 es
una respuesta totalmente correcta pero
no están preguntando qué porcentaje así
es que hay que convertir esto a
porcentaje y lo más fácil para esto es
primero convertir el número a decimal
hagamos eso cinco cuartos de hecho
significa cinco dividido entre cuatro
hagamos entonces esta división voy a
cambiar de color lo voy a hacer en
magenta entonces 5 dividido entre 4
vamos a poner dos decimales más 5
dividido entre 4 nos da 4 cabe una vez
en 51 por 44 restamos 4 nos da 5 menos 4
nos da 1 ahora antes de bajar el 0 este
punto decimal que tenemos aquí lo
subimos y ahora si bajamos el 0
y dividimos 10 entre 4 esto nos va a dar
22 por 48 restamos 8-10 menos 8 nos da 2
bajamos el siguiente 0
bajamos el siguiente 0 20 entre 4 nos da
55 por 420 restamos 20 para obtener el
residuo de 0
así es que x es igual a 1.25 obtuvimos 5
cuartos que es igual a 54 que es igual a
1.25 hemos llegado entonces a que 100 es
1.25 por 80 o inclusive podríamos decir
que es 1.25 de 80 pero no lo hemos
expresado como porcentaje lo hemos
expresado sí como un número una parte
entera y una décima al esto podrías
verlo como un número mixto un entero y
un cuarto de 80 pero necesitamos
expresar lo como porcentaje pues es lo
que nos están preguntando y para esto
para expresar lo como porcentaje
literalmente tenemos que multiplicarlo
por 100 o lo que es lo mismo mover el
punto decimal dos lugares a la derecha
así es que esto es igual moviendo el
esto es 125 125 por ciento por ciento
deja de poner mejor el símbolo
ciento veinticinco por ciento y eso hace
sentido 100 es 125 por ciento de 80 80 y
100 por ciento de 80 100 es 1 y una
cuarta parte de 80 así es que tienes 125
por ciento de 80 así es que si está
correcto 100 es 125 por ciento de 80 es
más que el 100 por ciento ya hemos
concluido hemos resuelto el problema
tienes 125 por ciento de 80